welcome back ok I want to give you just
kind of a very brief overview of
something called non minimum phase
behavior in control systems so this is
something I talk about sometimes and I
just want to make sure that everyone
knows what I'm talking about when I say
non minimum phase and this is non
minimum phase and this is not going to
be super technical there's a lot of kind
of mathematical stuff you can talk about
with non minimum phase but I want you to
have like a gut feeling kind of some
physical intuition for what non minimum
phase means in a control system so
basically the kind of first thing I
think of for non minimum phase is that I
have a right a right half-plane zero so
I have a zero of my transfer function a
right half-plane
zero so if my transfer function G of s
remember this was the Laplace transform
of Y of s divided by U of s if this was
something like s s minus one
yeah let's get it right that's minus 1
over s plus 10
even though the system is stable because
the pole is in the left half plane let's
draw this in the complex plane so I have
my complex plane my pole is in the the
way left half plane at like minus 10
over here so the system is stable but
the zero is at plus one okay this is my
zero at plus one that makes the system
non minimum phase okay so anytime you
have a right half plane zero you should
be you should be worrying that your
system is non minimum phase and that's
going to have fundamental limits on the
robustness of your system and what you
can do with control so these are hard
systems to control that are non minimum
phase not impossible to control but
they're hard to get like really really
good performance because they have
strange characteristics now okay that's
that's kind of the diagnostic you can
diagnose if your system has this non
minimum phase another thing that I find
very useful is how it responds to an
impulse response
so the idea is that if you have a non
minimum phase system and you have an
impulse response or a step response it
essentially goes in the wrong direction
first and I'll show you what this means
the wrong direction first okay so what I
mean is let's do a step response let's
say I have u goes from you know zero to
one so u steps from zero to one at some
time then these strange non minimum
phase systems what would happen with Y
is that why would you know it's going
along it gets this step and it actually
turns in the wrong direction before
correcting that's very very strange
behavior so it actually goes in the
wrong direction before it then comes up
to its steady state value after this
step okay so this is the other kind of
classic physical observable phenomena of
these non minimum phase systems so
mathematically they have a right
half-plane zero physically the system
goes in the wrong direction given some
step or impulse before it then goes back
up to its its steady state value now
there are tons of systems that have this
behavior this is really common I think
the simplest example that that I like to
think about is a an aircraft and so
you're gonna get to see my lovely
drawing of an aircraft here let's see if
I can do this okay so I'm gonna have I'm
gonna have some aircraft with some wings
and some elevators okay that's my
aircraft there's happy people inside now
let's say that I want this airplane to
go up alright I want a higher altitude
so I want to climb in this aircraft what
do I do well the first thing that I do
is I kick my elevator I kick my elevator
to give this a downforce so I give this
thing a downforce by by jacking my
elevator up that's going to give my wing
a more positive angle of attack and it's
going to cause my my center of mass to
lift but notice that before the center
of mass can actually go up before I get
that a positive high angle of attack
center-of-mass actually went down right
because I basically kicked my elevator
to push the the tail of the plane down
so the the center of mass actually dips
before then it climbs because of the
increased lift so I think an airplane
gaining altitude is a great example of a
non minimum phase system where you you
have to first go down a little bit
before you can then go up and this is
kind of the extreme case where you dip
you know really really mind early maybe
like a meter or something it's a really
minor dip and then you might gain a ton
of altitude very very rapidly so the
system is kind of barely non minimum
phase for lots of lots of real aircraft
but it is an actual phenomenon that that
you can observe another example is let's
say you're trying to parallel park so
I'm just kind of going through all the
classic examples so parallel parking ok
so there's some car here there's some
car here and I and this car and I'm
going to try to back up into this spot
here well what's the first thing I have
to do to move my center of mass to the
right well the first thing I do is I
Jack my wheels out and I back my car up
this way so if you actually look at the
trajectory of my center of mass it
doesn't go directly to the right it
actually goes out before it comes in so
parallel parking is a non minimum phase
problem and it's part of the reason why
parallel parking is actually challenging
right like it's hard because you have to
counter intuitively move away before you
come back in okay so these are both non
minimum phase control problems because
the system the the physics of the system
forces it to dip in the wrong direction
before you can achieve your goal of
moving in the right direction okay and
this has some important implications for
robust control because I'm okay I'm just
going to be super hand-wavy here for a
minute but this is the right intuition I
think you can think of this dip as
almost like a little time delay it's not
it's not mathematically exactly like a
time delay but it has a lot of the same
characteristics there is some amount of
time
I have to be going in the wrong
direction before I can actually go the
direction I want and that just like time
delays give me fundamental limitations
on my bandwidth how fast of a of a
change I can track these non minimum
phase systems these little dips in the
wrong direction give me fundamental
limitations on how fast of a maneuver I
can track in a non minimum phase problem
so there's robustness limits given by
these right half-plane zeros okay so the
worst my graph the worse you know my my
non minimum phase system is the bigger
this dip the less robust I am to fast
changes and I have to settle for slower
more gradual control okay
so you know parallel parking is a slow
procedure you don't like do a super fast
parallel parking the you know airplane
altitude gain is you know not as super
aggressive you know it's not it's not
aggressive on the order of tenths of a
second so if you wanted to make this
more aggressive if you were designing a
fighter plane you would absolutely have
to take into account this non minimum
phase behavior you'd either try to
minimize the non minimum phase behavior
so make it as fast as possible or you
develop some kind of a you know some
control to compensate for this okay so
that that's the physical intuition non
minimum phase has these two you know
this mathematical characterization of
having a right half plane zero and this
physical characterization of dipping in
the wrong direction before finally going
in the right direction and there are
some fundamental physical limitations on
the control that you can achieve for
these non minimum phase systems because
you can think of this kind of like a
little time delay before you get what
you want okay okay so I'm gonna talk
about monta non minimum phase systems in
passing from now on so if I ever
mentioned this you kind of know what I'm
talking about
alright thank you